but yeah everything everywhere all at  once i thought was a great allegory and  very beautifully uh  told story about how  the gen xers feel about the world that  they created through complacency  and uh weren't smart enough to  stage a revolution in and  think more  uh  dangerously  like what are we to do  we had all the power we let it slip  through our fingers and now we're  letting the boomers rape our millennial  children  it's your fault take some [ __ ]  responsibility don't just stand there  like what was i supposed to do [ __ ]  you did this [ __ ] too  i get that their their point is like we  came from something crazy and we created  something crazy and we're just in the  middle just watching this [ __ ] i think  it was a great movie  in terms of whatever  i think the visuals i guess